how about the Rotary Club of Las Vegas
celebrating its 100th birthday last
weekend in the evening started with a
curtain call
[Music]
but not just any curtain this huge
curtain had almost as many lives as a
cat it hung in showrooms All Over Las
Vegas back in the day before taking up
residence in the collection of the UNLV
Library
you know many service clubs have a
tradition of hanging the banners from
visiting club members from across the
country or around the world but I don't
think any clubs going to match this
with Swanky musical interludes from
singer Chadwick Johnson and the LV retro
Vibe band the evening included an early
story of giving a 14 year old from oapa
Valley whose feet were amputated in a
farm accident the young Las Vegas Rotary
Club not only paid for several sets of
Prosthetics as he outgrew them but also
for his medical trips to Los Angeles
speaker Jack Sheehan telling edge of
your seat stories about Las Vegas from
Bugsy Siegel to one of the country's
biggest pot dealers who called Las Vegas
home even after a new identity in the
witness protection program
quite a night and happy 100th to the Las
Vegas Rotary Club and current president
Katie Crockett thanks so much for having
me as the MC at the historic Fifth
Street School downtown and thanks to the
committee and the production team that
pulled it all off Heather